for uh for you tom like when jackass
first came out
did you feel like oh these are my allies
this is like a progression of what i'm
doing or did it feel like
they were sort of taking what you did i
remember i went to like the screening of
it
i remember seeing you there i was like
no way
but that was for the movie not the
series oh right right right
yeah no i mean i remember it was i think
i was in new york when it first came out
and i was kind of like
yeah i thought it was amazing like it
was definitely
different i didn't think it was the same
thing because
you guys were kind of more like physical
more
skateboard oriented too like my show
like because i was a skateboarder but
i always kind of we i was trying to do
more like a david letterman type show
you know
yeah and you guys were definitely doing
more of the the physical stunts and
stuff
which i uh was sometimes kind of
i was shocked you know like uh that uh
but i don't know like dude i don't know
if we really met each other right away i
don't think
i don't think i remember i remember kind
of walking by each other at that
screening and i was just sort of
you know really thrilled to to see
like to be in tom green's presence was
something pretty special for me
and it's a weird thing because it's like
i had only been really living in
you know the united states for a few
years at that point and
i don't know i i've real i've i've
learned something about myself over the
years which is
i i think i had like a lot of social
anxiety when i was like younger like i
got really nervous
meeting people and stuff so i didn't
really ever know like what to say
like when i was around like you guys or
you know
you know like when you're talking about
tony hawk you know like how you can get
to skate with tony hawk now and
someone just sent me some pictures of me
and tony skating back in 1999 and
i posted them on my instagram today but
it took me back to those years where i
was like
you know i was just sort of overwhelmed
and intimidated by people you know so i
was always
i think it was sometimes like i was kind
of like you know people misunderstood it
as like oh is this guy like not want to
talk to me but really i was just kind of
scared shitless
like whenever i would run into somebody
that i kind of was amazed by
you know and i just sort of sit there in
silence you know but um
did you find that or were you just not
not like i'm
not i don't think that it was really a
situation
where we were introduced or had a a big
conversation
so i i didn't have any uh
you know like i didn't find you
standoffish or anything i just found you
standing over there
ish yeah yeah it wasn't really we didn't
really kind of get to know each other
probably until we did the web show like
five years later you know right
yeah yeah i kind of like
worry about you guys a lot like not so
much
now but like because like
like you guys like actually really get
hurt
like right badly right like like i i
never really did the jumping off
things or right you know and so i kind
of like
i'm somewhat amazed that like um
that you guys are able to do some of
that stuff and not actually permanently
get hurt like
doesn't johnny knoxville actually really
kind of hurt himself pretty badly right
uh a number of times and i think that uh
it would be good for him to be very
careful
with his brain from this point forward i
think that yeah like concussions and
stuff
i think he's used up all of his free
concussions
so when you guys are doing stuff now
like you're doing you're doing another
movie now right we've been shooting
another movie yeah
so is it going to be like as physical
like are you going to do
as much sort of painful stuff
that's uh that's that's right tom yeah
so and so like like uh
is there any sort of there there must be
some i'm gonna kind of interview you now
for a second but
there there must be some like pressure
to
one-up the uh the last big stunt
and uh you know some things are kind of
maybe not one-uppable right like i mean
like are you concerned that maybe you're
going to push it too far
you know there is that concern
and um like if
if there was something you could imagine
like not ever
wanting to one-up like that in my mind
particularly for knoxville like one
thing we think oh please don't try to
one-up that
and then he totally went up to that
you upped it wow no he one and a half
dead
yeah specifically
like yeah well just don't don't uh you
know don't um
you know overdo it
be careful yeah right maybe be careful
while you're not being careful
right i mean we're pretty close to uh
having gotten away with it so i don't
want to say anything more
but then there's more there's more to do
but but the the majority of it
is in the can i probably shouldn't even
say that but i did
guess what i have the number 30 ranked
hot sauce on
all of amazon it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude